et la couture pour terminer côté hommes
paris capitale du prêt à porter avec le
salon mais aussi avec la semaine des
couturiers et des créateurs elle se
terminait aujourd'hui c'était la
présentation des collections de l'hiver
proches tendance nuance
yauba grégoire sens dessus dessous
c'était les deux sunu commins voyons les
dessus
nikos se change de look une base
classique tout de même superbe manteau
et costumes dans les dégradés blanche
les vestes ont des couleurs chaudes de
dur
et pour le soir espoir plus de smoking
genre pingouins mes habits de lumière
lamé argent balmain change aussi et
rajeuni si la base reste classique avec
ses vestes longues boutonnage bab al
massae faire jeune et voici sept vaise
petit revers boutonnage mots que l'on
dira à la mode pour le soir smokings
genre hidalgo très pur très beau
jean paul gaultier signe et persiste
dans le loufoque mais qu'on ne s'y
trompe pas à ce n'est que du spectacle
pris séparément ces modèles sont
parfaitement portable
et le sait c'est un de ceux qui fait le
plus gros chiffre d'affaires sa
clientèle jeune bien sûr il puise son
inspiration dans la rue et branchée pour
les autres moins jeunes
jean paul gaultier s'amuse beaucoup
qu'ils se rassurent nous aussi moi je
vais présenter avec le casque